Former Republican Senator Jeff flake says
that at least 35 Republican senators would
vote to remove Donald Trump if the Senate
impeachment vote were private.
So let's back up a little bit.
The entire time I've been talking to you about
impeachment.
I've been accurately saying, I believe that
as long as Republicans control the Senate,
Trump will not be removed by impeachment.
The house Democrats can do their impeachment
inquiry.
If it leads them to saying we are filing articles
of impeachment, they can do it, they can do
the impeachment trial.
But no matter what, once it goes to the Republican
controlled Senate, which there will be at
least until January of 2021 and I believe
until January of 2023 based on the the Senate
election map, you are not going to remove
Trump because Republicans would not vote to
convict Trump on an impeachment charge.
Now, I've not mentioned it, but implied in
this is that impeachment votes in the Senate
are public the way you see senators vote on
stuff.
Yay, nay, a up vote down vote.
The way they do that, they would publicly
vote on impeachment in that same way.
But in the back of my mind and that of many
others was the question of imagine that the
Senate impeachment vote was not public, but
instead it was private.
So at the end of the vote, you would get the
number of senators who voted to impeach and
the number of senators who voted to acquit.
Would you have some Republicans who would
be willing to vote for the removal of Donald
Trump if that's where the evidence brought
them?
Would Republican senators vote to impeach
Trump if they knew that their vote would not
be public and therefore they would potentially,
uh, not be subject to the political repercussions
of it?
And the growing idea according to a couple
of reports, is that the answer is yes.
We first heard from Republican political consultant,
Mike Merck, Mike Murphy and Mike Murphy said,
uh, on MSNBC that if the vote was private,
30 Republican senators would back impeachment.
Then we heard from former Republican Senator
Jeff flake who said at the Texas Tribune festival
over the weekend that it's not, or a Thursday,
it was, it's not 30 Republican senators that
would vote to impeach Trump.
It's more like at least 35 who would back
impeachment if the impeachment vote were private.
And because of the balance of power, you actually
don't even need 30 or even 35 Republicans
to get behind impeachment.
You would only need about 20 assuming that
all Democrats and independent senators voted
for it.
But this is mostly hypothetical because once
again, it's not a private ballot, it's a public
valid ballot.
Just like everything that goes on in the Senate.
There's one other element to this, which is
it's not as simple to say if the vote were
private, 35 Republicans would be in favor
of it because even if the vote were private,
those Republican senators who voted against
impeachment would come out and say afterwards,
even if it's a private vote, I voted against
impeachment.
And this would immediately put the spotlight
on the Republicans that don't come forward
and say, I voted against a convicting, and
they would either have to lie or admit it.
So it's sort of a fantasy that it would even
go down in this way.
But what this signals then is a huge cowardice
on the part of the Republicans because if
it's true that they're only willing to vote
to impeach if the vote is secret and it doesn't
have political ramifications for them, it's
merely a political calculation.
Now, the upside if we want to find a silver
lining here is that I guess they're not all
blindly loyal to Donald Trump.
The downside is they're afraid to act on it
unless it's done in a way that it will have
no consequences whatsoever.
I read a comment online when researching the
story that sums it up as they're not all traders.
Some merely have no integrity and it, it's
not even just lack of integrity.
There's also the issue of hypocrisy because
in addition to the lack of lacking integrity,
they would instantly be voting to impeach
a democratic president who had done all of
the things that Donald Trump has done.
This may not even be a decision they end up
having to make.
We're just at the beginning of the inquiry,
which happens before articles are filed, which
would happen before all of the other things
that we've discussed.
But if Jeff flake is only 20% correct, if,
uh, Mike Murphy is only 30% correct, that
means that there would be the desire from
enough Republicans in the Senate to impeach
that it could remove Donald Trump.
But Mark my words, you are not
going to see it under this current Republican
controlled set.
Let's take a break.
We will be back with much more right after
this